je n'ai une petite scie pendant des
petites bonnes sympa de sabratha salée
si j'aime bien c'est un mec qui rentre
dans un dans un bar et il devait donc le
serveur en accueil et il lui dit bonjour
monsieur qu'est ce que je peux faire
pour vous je vais vous prendre une
chaise
ok bah on part sur une 16,64 non non non
une chaise ou cronenbourg
[Applaudissements]
quand j'ai commencé
j'aime beaucoup
c'est un groupe d'amis tu vois un groupe
d'amis au belge et ils se connaissent
depuis très très très longtemps j'en ris
on est ensemble choisir à la naissance
quad qui se connaissent depuis hyper
longtemps il en est ensuite tous dans le
groupe
ils se sont mariés il en manquait 1 et
vient juste de se marier c'est patrick
patrick qui vient de se marier et il a
fait sa nuit de noces est donc juste
après la nuit de noces le rituel c'est
que fini là d'une noce ils se retrouvent
entre potes et craque une bière donc ils
sont là autour de tours du marais tout
il se raconte et toujours machin tout ça
va ça va ça va ça alors patrick samedi
sa nature ben je sais pas si je m'arrête
entre temps c'est que j'ai mal à la
gorge
patrick raconte puce annonce l'achat du
bien que freddy comment ça s'est passé
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
est la patrie
moi j'ai pas très côté manos où vous
avez un côté mais moi je trouve ça trop
intimes
j'ai pas envie très côté mac do ce
revers est améliorée on a beau ne sais
pas pourquoi toi tu raconterai pas en
patrick tu racontes à mulhouse je vous
racontais maintenu dans sa non c'est
très simple on est arrivé dans la
chambre
tu vois on arrivait dans la chambre des
pétales de rose partout on s'est
allongée train qu'ils consomment peu de
son punch de verser le champagne sur le
corps et les tétons excepté là elle me
regardait le dif et morel est excité
mais comme une faune c'est bien simple
si jamais voulu je me lançais
[Applaudissements]
la niche
c'est un instituteur tu vois il est là
et tout il est super cool
vraiment c'est les élèves l'adorent et
tout ça se passe super bien et là il
dans un cours ou agissez détendre c'est
la fin de l'année tous et des temps et
donc il leur pose la question quel est
selon vous le meilleur élève une belle
mort est à la une qui lèvent la main
ben moi monsieur une belle mort ce
serait un ce serait de mourir comme
grand père ah d'accord et il est mort
comme en grand père mais en fait il
s'est endormi
ah c'est vrai qu'on dit que c'est la
plus belle mort voilà un être qui
s'endort et qui est paisible c'est super
et donc quel est selon vous une mort
atroce
ben moi franchement ce serait de mourir
comme les copains de grand-père à et
comment ils sont décédés
les amis de grand père mais ils étaient
dans la voiture quand grimper récent
dormi
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
ces deux ses deux copines tout va dont
une blonde est déjà là avec sa pote est
tout à fait le temps je suis dégoûté cm
c'est vraiment je suis deg la schl au
bout de ma life 3 chez ma voiture c'est
celle que j'ai été de ma grand mère
mais j'arrête pas l'aventuré celle émise
par tous genres sur vince tallent mon
corps partout j'arrive pas à l'avant
mais par tous genres gelé mise partout à
part pas à la 250 mille km elle part pas
ça me rend fou et la voiture elle est
éclatée contre un mur effectivement tu
allais tout rouillé tout dégueulasse des
trous partout elle est invendable tu
vois si sérieux et touba écoute moi j'ai
une dernière solution apprécié pas ils
perdent légal toi tu veux avoir mon pote
tony sylva trafic un petit peu le
compteur dans les deux jours tu l'avancé
sur ma belle je te jure dans les deux
jours d'avancé sur elle
toi est donc assez sérieux mais je dit
vas-y va le voir tony tu viens
travailler longtemps et deux jours
d'avancé sur deux cas valoir le tony du
trafic le compteur tout bien lui fait un
peu de peinture parce que tony les cool
tu vois il me fait un peu de peinture
repères sont un petit peu à quelque
chose douze jours après on retrouve sa
copine alors tu as vendu ta voiture mais
t'es malade ou quoi là cinquante mille
bornes impossible avant
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
donc c'est un mec qui chante dans un bar
et donc le barman lui demande
bonjour monsieur que je veux qu est ce
que je peux vous servir et je me mets
toi qu'a fait d'accord tu es m trois
filles un pour moi un pour toi et pour
ta femme la nympho non pas sur nous
perdons jamais 3 a fait un bon moyen
pour toi est importé de famille info ado
parce que cet accent on s'en remet pas
il garantit un peu binaire
jonathan doit pour ta femme l'info mais
qu'il arrive le bar minutes et inzaghi
comme à ceux qui les touchent et siffle
enron il lui défonce la gueule papin pam
pam pam pam lemay qui part et revient le
lendemain matin
qu'est-ce que vous m que je joue ou
serveur hôte eu un bug projet d'accord
kamada un café pour moi avant toi pour
ta femme l'un à fond ma gueule ou comme
le dit il le jette en l'air
il est en miettes relate guy en
milliards il revient le lot de encore
mais qui regarde car ça tu allemagne
regarde comme ça il dissout mayenne
qu'est ce que vous voulez monsieur
jamais tout à fait un pour moi est un
portable un fauteuil café chez 32
nerveux
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
interprétation d'amaga savoir ce qu on
t'aime on avait à ses côtés des 30 m et
je dois dire à m il est venu voilà il a
rien au monde il est venu ce pour qu'il
fait avec nos chiens rien avant bon
allez si vous avez un peu d'oseille
non mais d'ailleurs étonné il avait fini
sa tournée juste à temps j'ai envie de
dire vrai de vrai ça faisait longtemps
que c'est apple
après j'ai dit et on m'a dit cuir